القدرة البريطانية على التفاوض
ينسفها أه البرلمان تمامًا بهذه الطريقة أه
بتسليم صلاحيات الشعب البريطاني
لبروكسل
حتى نبقى محتجزين في
الاتحاد الأوروبي
دون أن يتم وضع ذلك فعليًا على
الشعب في
شكل  صوت وأنت تعرف
مرارًا وتكرارًا أه جيريمي كوربين لا تقلق ،
سأنتهي قريبًا جدًا ،
أنت على حق ، هذا صحيح ، أنا آسف جدًا ،
حسنًا ، أعتقد أنني أعتقد أن هذا فقط
هذا هو  إشارة بالنسبة لي بنشاط
لكي ينتهي الأمر
بخير مرارًا
وتكرارًا ، لقد قال جيريمي كوربين إنه يريد
التصويت ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لكم جميعًا
وأشكركم جميعًا
على الاستماع بصبر ،
تهانينا لكم جميعًا
على ما تفعلونه  وشكراً جزيلاً لك
على
كل ما ستفعله لمواجهة
جميع المخاطر
التي ستجريها في
اتجاه الخطر
بدلاً من الابتعاد عنه لجعل
بلدنا ومجتمعنا أكثر أمانًا ، شكرًا
جزيلاً
لك